Hi, everybody. Dr. Connors here. I'm going to show you the use of this machine, the Atelier
Robin P220. This is a great right machine. So it's a right machine. It's easy light frequencies
and frequencies through a foot bath if you get the foot bath apparatus in order to get those
frequencies into the body to help heal cells. That's the whole idea of a right machine. This
is a very powerful right machine. This is a very simple right machine. It simply hasn't
run off switch and this is where you plug the bulb into. Obviously red goes into red. Black
goes into black. Black couldn't be any simpler. And then the bulb you use, we use this hammer
bulb, this overnight bulb. But literally you could use any right bulb. It doesn't make
any difference. But we write programs for people to use overnight, primarily because we want
you to get the right thing done overnight while you're sleeping. You have to sleep anyhow
so you might as well get treated while you sleep. So the hammer bulb is ideal because it's
plastic and cased. You can't break it even if it drops on the ground. You can certainly use
it all day long. Personally, I only have a hammer bulb at home. That's all I use even during
the day, what I'm right for you during the day. This machine has a port auxiliary port versus
tube. That's obviously if you're running a bulb, you have it on tube. If you're running the
foot bath, you put turn it on auxiliary. Here's the auxiliary port that you plug the foot bath
apparatus into right there. So it also has a built in scanner so you can do scanning. Of course,
we're not giving instructions on that, but we'll give instructions on a further video on how to do
scanning. But you can actually do scanning to get your frequencies that maybe you have some weird
thing going on, not feeling well. You don't know what it is. You can actually scan for different
frequencies. Now, the computer is what runs the program. So the computer talks to the machine via
this USB port that connects to the back of the machine. That's literally all the cords you have.
You have the cords to plug in the bulb. You have the cord to plug in the USB to communicate to the
machine. And then, of course, you have your power cord to run your computer. But your program is
going to look like this. So I put on there a whole bunch of my personal frequencies sets that I've
created and I'll put on more and more for people that have needs to different things. So there's some,
a lot of those are overnight sets as well. But you'll go to, let's go back to the home screen.
You'll go to open. This is what your home screen looks like. And you'll go to open program. So
99% of the time, you're going to see this. You're going to hit open program. You're going to go to
whenever program you want. And for those who I programmed a set for them, I'll put the letters AA.
So it comes up alphabetically first in this whole alphabetical set of programs.
It'll say AA and then your name. So it'll be, there's nobody up here now because this is generic one.
But it'll be right up on top. And then it'll be alphabetically the folders. So these are all my folders
that I personally created for people to use. And these are alphabetically that come with all the
rifes, all the different programs. So literally there'll be a good 2000 plus programs that you
could pick from and use. These are all alphabetical. So if I have diabetes, you can see there's multiple
diabetes programs. If I am dysentery, there's a dysentery program. There's a cytomegalovirus program.
There's just a ton of different programs to run. You can scroll through this and run these whatever
you see fit. If somebody in your family is not feeling well, it's a good idea to use the right first.
And then you would just click on the program. So let's click parasites fluke right there. And then you
just go up here and you hit run. Uh, that's it. Now it'll have a little noise depending on the frequency
that's running. The noise can change and the vulnerable light. Now you can hardly, you can't even see
that the bulb was lit, right? So it's in the daytime. We're showing this video in the sun. You
can't even tell that it's lit. Uh, at night, of course, you'll see a light coming out of that bulb.
That's why we tell you to put it under your covers right next to your body, snuggle with the bulb.
It will get warm, but not hot. And that's how you should use it. I don't want the bulb to keep you
awake at night. The only other light that comes out of this machine, which is nice, is just this power
button, this on off button here, which you can easily put a piece of black tape over it. If you want
to have literally no light coming from the machine. There's no EFFs coming from the machine, no
dangerous EMFs. The only EMFs that you would get is possibly from the computer. So we always suggest
once you hit run, you close the computer and go to bed. So the computer goes to sleep. The program
has already been sent to the right machine. There's nothing else you need to do. Go to sleep, put this
under your covers, snuggle with the bulb. You won't see any light. You'll hear that little noise.
And the light can change depending on what frequency is running. And the sound can change slightly
depending on what frequency is already. You can certainly put this machine at the bottom of your bed
underneath your bed. If you want to put it underneath your bed, you can put it on your bedside.
We always suggest the computer to go on your bedside. So it's ease of use. And then close the
computer to run the program. It's really easy. If you wanted to open it up and stop the program,
you can do that. But you can certainly like, oh, I have to get up and I'm going to leave for the day.
And I don't want this thing running all for the next two hours. Maybe you only ran half of your
program or something. You can stop it by just turning off the switch. That's the easiest way to do it.
That's what I tell people to do it. If you turn it back on, it will continue running that program.
Otherwise, just leave it off until the next day. Then you can open it up and stop it. Otherwise,
you could leave it on. Personally, I always leave my not. And just let it time out. But everybody's
different. But it'll what you want to do. Easy, peasy, right use. It's very simple to use. We want you
to use it. So most people just get this out of the box and put it together and don't watch this
video. But we want people to know that it's safe. It's easy to use, safe for pregnant women,
safe for babies, safe for everybody in your household. It's frequencies. Everything's
with a quantum physics perspective, it's frequencies, vibrating energy that's vibrated
in a frequency. So we want you to use this machine and be blessed from it. Thanks so much.